[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très bizarre que les préciser
parce que la phrase en entrée je vais te
pousser les eaux c'est très bien ça va
vous je le suis content de retrouver les
quatre tiers tous les mercredis c'est un
bonheur merci bonjour sa fait plaisir
c'est ce pas vous dire la même chose à
la fin de la rubrique
non vous n'allez pas mettre ce que je
sais je vais vous mettre ce que vous
voulez à ça le problème c'est que je
fais ce que j'ai envie d'y aller
une question bonjour je m'appelle
huguette j'ai entendu dire que cyril
hanouna était si populaire que l'année
prochaine son anniversaire serait un
jour férié
est ce vrai mais c'est une très bonne
question et guette mais non c'est une
rumeur mais prochaine pour son
anniversaire si la syrie le fera juste
passé la patrouille de france au dessus
de chez be et on inaugurera à la salle
de réunion ultra high tech qui finance
depuis quelques mois au csa car il
voulait vous savez chaque année quand
même l'anniversaire de cyril reste quand
même un événement majeur de la vie
française et donc pas mal de vedettes
tiennent à les lui c'est de souhaiter
des coûts comme la semaine dernière au
téléphone ou en live
[Musique]
mao
des jo les anniversaires enfin gros
bisous et merci d'avoir à 4 minutes
et en plus vous fait des cadeaux pour
vous amener vous avez pas kiffer voilà
ta table au bout du rouleau
en même temps ils y étaient tous avaient
les autres t'as qu'à ce jour michel
évidemment qu'ils étaient au courant de
l'anniversaire puisque son cadeau à
cyril c'était la venue de la sublime
kamilou sur le plateau vous venez la
prestation des siens on peut la revoir
elle chantait self control dans une
combinaison argent très légèrement
moulante ne sais pas si c'était ma
meilleure idée car avec un vêtement
pareil jean michel et maxime
ils ont eu du mal à se concentrer sur
les paroles on a reçu la lettre emballés
dans du film alimentaire
[Applaudissements]
le plus trop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je crois que je dois loup à la culotte
dire un adolescent qui regardaient en
douce tcl au catalogue de la redoute
maintenant vous avez reçu beaucoup
d'appels ce soir là et notamment de
votre grand ami patrick sébastien c'est
parce que ce n'était pas seul il a voulu
vous passer quelqu'un c'était sympa mais
chez les chroniqueurs ya eu un gros
malaise à cause d'une mauvaise van damme
vas-y il passe michèle torr besoin
c'est en voiture
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas vu la fin de l'extrait d'ailleurs
parce que j'étais petit et fois j'étais
choqué parce que j'adore michèle torr la
tournée âge tendre et tête de bois et
chaque année en perdant alors je me suis
dit c'est la vie j'ai eu très peur
j'aime beaucoup
non non ben moi aussi j'aime beaucoup
voilà
joie
jours
merci beaucoup de joie vous ont appelé
pour fêter votre anniversaire mais y en
a un qui a brillé par son absence c'est
qui le kanji mais c'est vrai vous avez
rompu ou quoi kenshi vous avez raison
j'ai oublié celui-ci soit là et vous
avez une baie ou pas je sais pas je sais
que ça vous a peiné car les mois passent
et vous aimez toujours autant ses
chances qu'ils adorent 1 comme un cri
tanoh c'est une déception c'est un
bâtard bon rythme et je veux dire me
chanter pendant la publicité non moi
j'aime bien non j'ai un die in my et
elle a plus de mal regardé bien sa tête
[Musique]
je chantais j'avais jamais le terrain
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
suivez-moi macao et pascal et chewbacca
aux armées à paris parce que ça n'a rien
à voir mais l'a dit qu'il aimait pas les
violences il a prédit qu'il aimait
peindre est à féliciter laisse tomber
quesque quand je regarde les anciennes
vidéos quelques tu fais à l'ancienne
quincaillerie comme so toilettes et je
veux aujourd'hui tu a félicité la dore
alors le fola de jardiner magique et si
ça me l'a rassuré géraldine syrie n'aime
pas que kenji ouais non il aime aussi la
musique électronique comme monde au tec
n'en arrête au plus grand plaisir
d'agatha notre nouvelle productrice qui
travaillait avant avec stéphane bern
c'est important de noter pour comprendre
sa réaction
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aux accusés
fois je
[Musique]
dambach beauvoir beauvois jeu
que vois je
lucien
[Musique]
[Rires]
une fois j'ai eu beau point du bo3
com
il ya d'habitants
elle m'a dit laura et je te détail cela
donne 5 4 avec 6 points q bon être
courageux regarder les choses en face
vous avez un problème
un quoi enfin si vous êtes trop généreux
voulait donner à manger à tout le monde
c'est bien de manger mais il faut boire
aussi donc j'en voyais tout le monde au
bistrot gelé ses principes au ralenti
les images et comme ça on découvre t pmp
en mode bourré
[Musique]
pour moi le j'aime pas je pas une presse
ont freiné en quatuor
donc tiré lundi qu'il est ton propos à
part de me remettre à ma maman je sais
que je serai plus juge de mon propos je
pense qu'à ça c'est clair c'est le cycle
de la vie à sa hav agr c'est ça c'est la
chaîne alimentaire et la vie
sandra minutes sans ma vie ça fait comme
en seconde ça peut être mise en seconde
non cette non le sens où moi je vois ça
merci
trop mal mais là ça me plaît pas du tout
aux normes et là tu vas place roger j
toujours nous a aidés madjid je suis
jaloux à être fantastique animés ou fait
premièrement film suit groupe l'est dans
tous les sens hercog tout à fait aller
les chercher
c'est une bonne surprise moi dans
l'émission ne suis pas fan du tout moi
je me rendrai quels sont les pierrafeu
bas je trouve qu'elle ait changé
[Applaudissements]
si vous nous rejoignez il ya d'autres
choses c'est les captures de jean luc
lemoine comme tous les mercredis
acceptant que j'ai une ici alors sinon
la semaine dernière on a eu aussi une
très belle programmation avec notamment
wycleaf jean où la championne régionale
d'imitation de chat n'est pas là
cohérence y en a pas wyclef jean qui a
fait l'unanimité pour sa performance à
son humilité car on peut le dire on
était tous fans qui viennent vous le
connaissiez vous syrien sur wyclef jean
si je vous demande le nom du groupe dont
il faisait partie fugees les fugees
exactement ça serait bien de le dire aux
gens qui sont régis avait reconnu et
franchement le titre est exceptionnel on
était très très très grave
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le corriger les quelques groupies les
foodies victimes
ça prend ça fait dix ans pour ceux qui
connaîtraient pas grave le vigile s'est
pas même délire c'est bordeaux des blues
ont ouvert avec des poils partout dans
cette photo il
mais j'adore ça vous va très bien cette
coupe à un maxime du milieu qui reste un
bon fils en question et on a reçu la
championne de miaulements comme me
disait c'est important de l'avoir
l'allemagne a pas de fans par et julien
goulet à elle a pris des coups de
pression d'autres émissions qui la
voulait exactement alors juste pour le
plaisir des yeux et des oreilles et
aussi parce que comme le disent et cyril
c'était une exclu tpm p ce programme va
revoir les images fait un tabac par
mavuba les attentions et la foire au
jambon l'homme entre nous
[Applaudissements]
alors comme nous sommes une émission
médias la semaine dernière on a beaucoup
parlé d'animaux sains et notamment de
cochon il a plein à la télé en ce moment
d'aller des cochons nom des animaux ils
vous avez fait peur alors ça peut
paraître anecdotique mais je voulais
absolument vous passer cet extrait pour
la réaction de maxime gainey ça fait mon
bonheur
alors vous allez voir syrie va faire une
grosse vanne et maxime alias monsieur
premier degré va prendre ça comme une
info limite des goûters d'être le seul à
ne pas être au courant
vous allez comprendre oui et dans les
élevages leur coupe la queue aux caisses
que les cochons quand il sent trop près
l'un de l'autre et se bouffent
artistique et accessible et je passe la
même chose dans les loges
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il te battre c'est énorme ça c'est
énorme
c'était une blague on se bouffe pas là
qu en loge ces écoutes représentaient
des ententes maxime mais c'est qu'il
formait avec lui c'est qu'il est dans sa
bulle tout le monde se marre à huy capte
rien un autre exemple à ce que vous
appelez la semaine dernière la blague
que vous avez diffusé sur sur les deux
vieux alzheimer qui veulent s'acheter
une glace elle a un des deux qui va et
qui dit qu'il n'a pas besoin de prendre
des notes
enfin guillaume ira pas gros succès en
plateau tout le monde était parti sur
l'autoroute du rire sauf que sur la
bande d'arrêt d'urgence
y'avait maxime quittant warning unknown
[Applaudissements]
rien compris
j'ai compris c'est déjà triste comme
séquences et campus maxime demande à
jean michel je lui expliquais la blague
dernière alors là parce que niveau
clarté jean-michel il n'est pas dernier
il n'est pas dans le top 100 non plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait une belle transition pour le top
gênante à j'adore c'est ça une préfère
cette compilation des moments là je
serai plus que ça mais non on aime tous
le mais ça c'est encore 7 6 et 6
exceptionnel à ses fins il a su résister
à des objets dans la compilation des
moments les plus bizarres de tpm paix je
suis foot ça bonjour géraldine un bon
jour cyril bonjour merci d'être avec
nous alors des troupes thierry sol en
crise au lendemain du vol de faire
en l'occurrence aussi un footing va
remonter salut l'année s'impatienter en
défaut n'a pas atteint rosillo
[Musique]
il s'appelait suis comme ça les autres
mais tous nos gars
[Musique]
on épargne française pass foncier
le feu
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce dimanche
[Musique]
fini par acheter autant d'agents
jamais vous parce que vous avez n'auriez
dans un zoo oui toute façon j'adore les
animaux donc c'est vous et mêlera louvre
[Applaudissements]
c'est là